would like to introduce some technical
details so
technical I would like to encourage our
viewers to post the comments under the
live so we have a chance as well to
collect those and respond them during
during our discussion
the topic of minimum wages has been
around in the parliament for some time
including here in the in this place
recently the parliament adopted the
rules new rules on on the protection of
the minimum wages so I would like to ask
you Mrs Young areas let's cast more
light as well on the basic concept what
is the adequate minimum wage why we need
it and why we need the specific new
rules if you can respond to that
um I think inadequate minimum wage
differs from one member states to the
other because we know that of course in
Europe
the purchasing power in the different
member states varies the prices varies
but we see that in all member states
people having
problems in paying their rents their
groceries and their energy bills
so it's clear that especially those
people who worked so hard for us during
the coffee times we call them the
essential workers or those we cannot
miss on the labor markets are sometimes
also the ones who go home with the
letters with the most little uh paycheck
and this director says we want each
member said
to do two things we want them to check
whether or not you can have a decent
life
from your minimum wage so is the minimum
wage adequate is it adequate
when you look at a certain basket of
wooden surfaces is it adequate compared
to other wages in the member states
uh and if not adequate and we think that
in 23 of the 27 member states the
minimum wage is not adequate
there's work to be done and the minimum
wage should be raised to a adequate
level
the second thing is that this directive
says
for a country it's better if more people
fall under the coverage of a Collective
Agreement
and we asked the member states
to push for a coverage rate of 80
percent of the workers under a
Collective Agreement and if not make a
plan how to come there
I see and creating this living and
working conditions equal
um is still a challenge in memory member
states given the
um given the current context as well
with energy crisis and Rising prices uh
Mr ratke uh how this how this new rules
would be reflected in um or how this can
improve the living conditions of workers
well it's it's improving the living
condition in in uh in two different ways
on the one hand we have the member
states where we have a statutory minimum
wage that we have as Agnes has mentioned
now uh new rules new criteria
which have to be included into the
debate on the question what is a fair
and adequate minimum wage and as Agnes
described in many many countries we have
difficulties that people can spend the
money that is needed for funding in the
daily life and daily sinks we are not
talking about luxury things we are
talking about daily life
and so this criteria will help will help
uh for instance it is of course uh the
question of purchasing power uh will be
included so this is directly linked to
the question of of the costs of daily
life and on the other hand
um
uh this is only one part of the
directive because we do not have
statutory minimum wages all over Europe
and we do not want to force anyone into
statutory minimum wages and the other
key issues of course the question of
increasing the coverage of the
collective agreements so we have two
ways uh where we improve uh that a
situation for the uh for the for the
workers in the European Union is getting
better and better at least in the next
years I see you mentioned as well that
times are very difficult and as well I
could take one comment from Facebook
from fenrir who says that really the
minimum wage is uh basically consumed by
inflation so this as well adds to
people's expectations because from what
people are commenting mainly is a little
bit of a confusion in between
um
um in the concept that the minimum
adequate minimum wages on the European
level would mean that the countries
would sort of introduce an equal uh
equal minimum wages everywhere uh for
example there are a lot of differences
um
if you look at the numbers the minimum
wages in Bulgaria is 330 euros and on
the other hand in Luxembourg 2000 so
people
expect naturally that this new rules as
well would tackle that what would you
tell them why this is not possible
to have the the same numbers all over
Europe well of course it is a uh of
course a question of what is
economically possible and of course the
economic possibilities in in Luxembourg
in in Germany in Austria in in the
Netherlands uh you you cannot compare
with with Romania and Bulgaria so we
have different starting points where we
are coming from but the the most
important thing is that we can ensure
that through the work of this criteria
and that through the aim of 80 of
collective agreements coverage we have
progress everywhere and that is I think
the the most important thing
no one promised to have the same minimum
wages uh in Bulgaria like in the in the
Netherlands or in Germany this would be
crazy to give a promise like that that
that is a lie but to ensure progress
everywhere that is what we promised and
I think that is what we deliver and and
we are like in this criteria saying you
should be able to lead a decent life
that's not a luxury life as genital but
it's a decent life and you have to be
able to pay your bills send your kids to
school
for a health care insurance
Etc so and I think if we are able to
make this basket of Putin services
it's
um hopefully in in Bulgaria also cheaper
than in Luxembourg but you should be
able to buy these basket of foods and
services from your uh from your weights
this is one Criterium the second
we want that in every member states
the minimum wage is following suit to
what the average weights are are doing
and and that's also an importance
a message and with these two promises a
basket of goods and a good
uh
um a good relationship with the average
weight
we can push for a better life for very
much workers in in Europe and that will
not lead to one minimum wage all over
Europe I think not in my lifetime we're
going to
uh see that but we want progress
everywhere and we want all workers in
Europe whether they live in Bulgaria or
Luxembourg in Lithuania or in the
Netherlands they should all be able to
lead a decent life with the minimum wage
I see then we have some comments of
appreciation Varan kazotan I suppose
from Hungary is welcoming the
introduction of European minimum wage so
uh that's that's one of the comments
from our audience
um that is good to hear great please go
on this way yes especially from Hungary
yeah yeah yeah
as they abstained
so when talking about the member states
now member states they have two years uh
periods to comply with the rules uh what
what would be your message to step up
this process or how to really
um convince them
a transportation period is uh always
used in European legislation
because you want member states to be
able to adjust their legislation to the
new European rules
but as you have mentioned before all
over Europe we see
unprecedented inflation figures
for instance in my country the inflation
is higher the highest since the Second
World War
so this is really exceptional
and I would hope that member states will
not wait the full two years before
implementing this directive they can
start now
because now at this moment people have
problems in making all ends meets so uh
although I cannot force them I can
happily invite them warmly recommend
that they go quickly on transposing this
because people need money in their
pockets
and who can say no with such advisor
and great so as they are some more
information we could as well send the
greetings to people from Malta Portugal
even Bangladesh Hungary Moldova and
Denmark who are watching this live at
the moment
um we could touch upon as well
um the Equal Pay
um as there is as there as there is a
gap between the men and the uh and the
women because uh frankly the figures say
that 60 of minimum wage earners are
women so legislation can help close this
Gap is there as well
um some instrumental Tools in this
legislation which could close this Gap
uh it it's it's clear that uh um if you
look here you you mentioned the numbers
uh who are earning minimum wages all
over Europe
it's the same sectors everywhere so it's
the Cleaning sector it's uh the
agricultural workers Hospitality uh but
also retail
and if member states are now adjusting
the minimum wage to a higher level it's
indeed women who profit from that
although of course I do hope that men
also can live a decent life from their
minimum basis
uh uh and the
directive itself is not aiming
especially
on equal treatments but because there
are more women working in this low dates
jobs
they will profit more and I think it's
high time that they profit more
and if if I may add this I think to
ensure that we have more Collective
agreements or more coverage of
collective agreements
will have also because I I have worked
for a trade Union as an activist and the
the two of us we negotiated
Collective agreements and there are no
Collective agreements for man and for
for women so I think to to ensure that
we have higher numbers will also help in
in closing that Gap but especially for
for the situation we came up with the
legislation on the paid transparency so
there is some special action some
concrete action to ensure that we get
rid of that cabinet and Oliver from
Facebook is asking if the minimum wage
is not the same across Europe even in
other European currency it means that
there is no minimum wage so this is as
well one of those comments I was I was
saying we collect a lot but um you
mentioned already
um the statutory minimum wage and the
collective bargaining so these are
basically two methods already present in
member states uh how the legislation
will go about this will it try to unify
or will it keep as well these
differences in member states no of
course we have we have different systems
and different traditions and of course
this was clear from the very beginning
of the uh of the negotiations also
between the two of us that we do not
want to spoil a national traditions and
National systems that was one fear
always repeated from Sweden from Denmark
or you are spoiling our system and I can
say no we are not so they are does these
Traditions but to to to combine it with
with uh with criterias and with rules
and with the political aim to have 80
coverage you are not harming uh running
and when well functional systems we are
strengthening systems where it is not
working in the in the cleaning systems
where it is not working in the in the
correct way that is helping but where
everything is working well uh uh we we
do not we do not spoil it but I want to
come back to the argument so if we do
not have the same minimum wage all over
Europe there is no minimum wage
sorry to say but this is this is
bollocks because the the the rental of
an apartment in Bulgaria is of course
something different than the rental of
the apartment in Munich in Berlin uh in
Amsterdam or in Paris so you cannot say
we we do not have access to Fair payment
to Fair minimum wages if we do not have
the same number
because we do not have the same prices
okay
could you explain us what the European
Parliament has achieved in concrete
measures stemming from this directive
I think
two things mainly and that's one that
member State should check the adequacy
can you lead a decent life in Bulgaria
from this minimum wage
and if not adjust the pay and we know
because there are international
standards
for instance the organization of
economic cooperation in Europe
has these standards where
they measure the adequacy of minimum
minimum wage if you look at this
a figure
for 23 of the 27 member states the
minimum wage is too low and this was
even before this skyrocketing
inflation figures so testing the
adequacy and work on the adequacy of the
minimum wages is
it's about real money
and the other thing pushing for more
people under the coverage of a
Collective Agreement
and it's also
in my opinion and I don't say this
because Dennis and IBU are former Trade
Union uh Trade union negotiators but
because I'm deeply convinced that people
with a Collective Agreement
have more fair and decent pay and in
this director we also made clear that
trade unions should be welcome
in a company should be able to organize
the people we should indeed also make it
clear
uh that's collective bargaining is
something to strive for instead of just
a nuisance uh which it has been treated
before in the banking crisis
we are changing the tone which are
changing the recipe book for uh economic
policies from uh from Europe and be
putting I think a well-deserved
spotlight
on those workers we tend to forget but
from which it was clear during the covet
crisis
that if they would not have cleaned the
hospitals if they would not have
distributed the parcels if they had not
uh Cooked our food
or
nursed people when they're ill
the society was really a problem so
there were a lot of people who just were
able to sit behind their laptop and do
their online meetings but those people
really did important work and I think
it's now time that they get the pay rise
okay
um this might be as well coming again
with the digital transition many jobs
will undergo changes and a very likely
artificial intelligence as well will
also step in
how can this affect the social rights
and conditions on on of employees in the
future if you look a little bit in the
future will as well this be affecting
the
um the conditions
I don't think this directive per se is
covering this but at all the legislation
for instance the legislation for
so-called platform workers so let's say
the drivers of Uber or the food
deliveries were
biking in all the major cities in in
Europe they are now
often
denied their work status so the platform
is saying these are not workers these
are self-employed and therefore they
don't need to guarantee a minimum wage
they don't need a guarantee social
benefits but luckily we are working on
legislation in this field I think it's
very necessary because indeeds
artificial intelligence computer systems
digital Revolution will touch
upon a lot of jobs and we need to be
prepared Dennis is also working on this
legislation yeah we and we are talking
about more than 5 million people in the
European Union working in their
platforms and of course there are people
who are self-employed and are originally
self-employed and we do not want to
force them into labor contracts but you
have a lot of people as art as described
who are denied in getting access to
minimum wages to Social Security and
that is not acceptable this has nothing
to do with self-employment this is Bogo
self-employment and this is robbery of
public money because in the very end the
solidarity uh the the
we all together have to to to take
responsibility for the people who who
are falling through the net because they
do not have access to to social security
and that has to stop and that is why we
are taking concrete action on this then
we have a question from the other side
from the side of the businesses how the
member states can can implement the
directive in a way that it wouldn't
carve their competitiveness or the
competitiveness of the businesses of the
companies
what would be the
here I think we should make a little
difference between let's say
the butcher with two people working for
him
or let's say the hairdresser with one a
woman a woman woman working for her
and
the big companies because we know that
uh
quite a numerous amount of people are
working for big
cleaning companies for big
distribution for for a big
nursing a
employment
and I think those companies
have earned a very big amount of money
during the coffee time so I think I I
don't feel sorry
for this large multinational companies
who are trying to keep people in the low
payment I think we should at member
state level see how we can
uh help uh the small and medium-sized
companies to also
pay a fair weights well on the other
hand it's also clear that if people have
more money in their pockets they're also
being able to buy these breads of the
baker go to their hairdressers go to the
butcher so it's also economically
a sound to raise the wages because then
people have more uh to to pay and and I
like to add the implementation of the
directive this is not up to the company
this is up to the to the member states
because this directive is an issue for
the member states and not uh in the
first step for the uh for for the uh for
the companies uh and and you do not have
to forget or you have to keep in mind
that the question of national long-term
productivity is one of the criterias we
introduced now into the question uh of
the uh um of raising the minimum wages
and so
if the raise increase of the minimum
wage does fit with national productivity
long-term productivity that cannot be a
problem okay the very last question as
our time is
running out I would like to ask you
because this type of rules are part of
the European social pillar what we can
expect still in the future as well from
the European Parliament in improving the
social conditions of of people of
citizens
no the first one has already been
touched upon the platform
directive I do hope that we also will be
able to take some measures on the issue
of occupational health and safety
you see that awesome clear during the
covet crisis a lot of mental problems
a rush so protecting People's Health and
make everyone being able to be at work
and still stay healthy it will be a
topic and perhaps we could also from the
European Parliament push for let's say
not only measures on the let's say
electricity market energy markets but
also how to compensate people
who really have problems in paying their
bills and I think they are we are
working now on a care strategy European
strategy that was also an initiative
from the parliament the the commission
took it over we are now we worked on the
ini on Mental Health I'm not sure what
the commission is going to deliver there
but but you have several things which
are which are ongoing and implementing
the social pillar International right
into European right into European law
this is an ongoing process and hopefully
it will not stop with this term of the
parliament okay thank you very much
thank you very much for accepting the
invitation and being here in the
discussion and I would like to thank you
viewers as well for watching our lives
and of course stay tuned for the future
upcoming activities which we are
planning in uh um in the coming weeks
and months thank you very much
thank you